[Music]
the loud house focuses on the 11-year
old Lincoln loud and is life with ten
sisters who all have strong
personalities
today we've reimagined what all these
characters would look like in the modern
world wait until you see the tiny Lisa
if you're new to our channel don't
forget to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up if you love the loud house now
let's check out eleven two out house
characters then and now land allowed
plan allowed may just be six years old
in the loud house but she already has a
mind of her own and doesn't want to
blend in with her twin sisters
personality she's funny sometimes crazy
and she loves to tinker around and be
the Handy woman of the house you usually
see her in her denim overalls and a
snapback and this is what we thought she
looked like in the modern world we think
she'll never grow out of her tomboy
things but she's definitely rocks it
even more as an adult
her hair is longer and we love that she
was striking a pose of course she's also
much taller what do you think is this
the land allowed you to imagine as a
modern cartoon character did you know
that Lana's got her name from a
real-life Lana who's one of kris
savino's sisters kris is the creator of
the show and the story is based on his
own life and a large family although it
has been noted that even our version of
modern-day Lana doesn't look anything
like his sister
but Lana isn't the only name you can
find on Christmas family tree stay tuned
to see which other loud sisters are
actually Kris savino sisters in real
life
Lenny loud Lenny is the second oldest
member of the loud family and she's one
of our favorites she's quite a
fashionista and if you've seen our
videos where we've shown what she looked
like at a younger age you know she was
always this fashionable her white
sunglasses are completely iconic but
Lenny isn't complete without her fun and
outgoing personality here's what we
thought she'd look like as a modern-day
character on the loud house as an adult
Lenny loud definitely got even more
fabulous than she was at 17 sure of her
dress is still the same but check out
that long blonde hair we're also loving
that a red earrings match the lipstick
as well as the nail color and of course
who can forget about the iconic
sunglasses Lenny would definitely make
an amazing real-life big sister Lenny's
name was inspired by a character called
Lenny from a novel called Of Mice and
Men Lenny which has a different spelling
and comes with two ends and the letter e
at the end is a boy but he has the same
innocent an outgoing personality as says
Lenny from the loud house Kris Savino
did note that her character changed a
lot is the story of the loud family
develop but we're not sure if it'll ever
change to the point where Lenny will
look like the modern-day Lenny we've
shown you
Lincoln loud of course the loud house
story mainly follows the life of Lincoln
loud and how he's actually living it's
the only boy in a family with 11
children you see him get annoyed alot
but most of the time he appreciates
having ten sisters more than having ten
brothers Lincoln is the only member of
the family with white hair and will
explain the story behind it in just a
second but here's how we've reimagined
Lincoln in the modern world our version
of Lincoln might have the same clothes
but we've added a goatee and a slightly
better looking hair he also looks like
he's packed on a few muscles okay here's
why Lincoln has white hair salado's
characters were originally designed as a
family of rabbits they still have the
same name but once Chris Savino was told
that turning them into humans might be a
better option they all lost the white
fur except for Lincoln it's also why you
see him with a chip tooth Chris also
said that Lincoln is the exact same
model as the rabbit just have the ears
the nose and remove the clothes and
there you have it what do you think
would be a modern Lincoln's job Lowell
aloud if you have a large family you
probably have at least one sibling is
very sassy and loves to dress up we have
to admit Lowell out is our favorite diva
this sassy six year old really doesn't
hold back and she loves to throw a
tantrum she's full of attitude as most
child beauty pageant contestants are
we've already reimagined her in several
alternative universes but we absolutely
love our version of a modern-day Lola
of course she's still rocking her pink
look she's got pink lips a pink dress
and even a pink eyeshadow she also looks
significantly taller than the
six-year-old Lola we've also added some
pink gloves that make her look like a
true princess her hair got slightly
longer and she still has her crown what
do you think with Lola be able to win a
few beauty pageants speaking of Lola did
you know that while most of the other
names came from Krista Vino's family
Lola is actually Chris's wiener dog
looks like the creator of the show
really did keep it all in the family and
managed to portray most of his family
members how old do you think she is on
this photo we're guessing she'd about 21
Lily loud at just 15 months Lily Louds
one of the most mysterious characters of
the show well she does have the
personality of a normal baby it would be
fun to see her grow up and develop her
own skills and talents just like her
siblings oh that we don't feature Lily
much on our Channel we've decided to
reimagine her as a much older version
here she is she looks like she's a
teenager with a very fun personality
probably similar to her sister Lenny
her hair is up in a ponytail and we're
predicting that she'll love the color
purple we've added purple lips a purple
hair tie as well as the shirt and a
towel what do you think Lily is
definitely a fun character to reimagine
as an older version especially because
she's so tiny did you know that her name
was actually chosen because it was on
Chris savino's baby girl name list how
awesome is it that most of the creators
life became a popular cartoon with
adorable characters like Lily loud what
do you think Lily's traits will be as
she grows up we have a feeling she'll
either really love languages or just be
completely crazy
Laurie loud if you have an older sibling
there's a good chance you've had to
listen to the I'm older argument at
least once in your life now imagine
being the oldest in a family with 11
kids we're pretty sure you'd act the
same as Laurie as the oldest in the
family Laurie is slightly grumpier than
the rest and spends the majority of her
time on her phone talking to her
boyfriend
well we've reimagined her as a
modern-day character and there's no
phone in her hands however she does look
completely grown-up and we think that's
exactly what she looked like as an adult
she got a bit taller her hair is longer
and we decided to dress her in typical
Laurie clothes we also kept her usual
blue eye shadow but added just a bit
more makeup to look what do you think
the name Laurie also comes from one of
Chris lovino sisters whose names all
actually start with a letter out but
don't worry it seems like the real-life
Laurie doesn't share the same
personality as a cartoon version what do
you think would be a dolt Laurie's job
we totally see her working in a beauty
salon
LuAnn loud all right this is quite a
funny one LuAnn is one of our favorite
characters because she's not afraid to
be herself even though it seems like no
one really appreciates her jokes we love
her crazy style and her hilarious
personality she seems so much fun to be
around and it seems like a modern-day
LuAnn is exactly the same here's our
version of what LuAnn would look like
today she's no longer 14 years old she
does look much older we've over
exaggerated her makeup because we feel
like the modern-day LuAnn would stand
out just as much as the 14 year old her
hair also got longer but we capture
iconic yellow outfit and added a few
extra ties in her hair doesn't LuAnn
remind you of Miranda sings we're pretty
sure the jokester will start her own
YouTube channel at some point in her
life
LuAnn was also the name that came from
Chris savino's actual sister but he
hasn't mentioned if the real-life
version is actually as hilarious as
LuAnn loud we're pretty sure her jokes
only got better when she became an adult
and we better family still doesn't
appreciate her witty puns but that's
okay because we certainly do Lucie loud
if there's one thing we've learned from
the
house it's that no matter how different
you are you're still a part of the
family even though the eight-year-old
Lucy tends to be dark community she
still has people that love her including
us she's one of our favorite characters
and we love how she unintentionally adds
comedic timing to all her scenes
we're pretty sure Lucy's look isn't just
a phase so we've decided to reimagine a
modern-day Lucy with the same dark
clothes her bangs are still covering her
eyes her dark hair is short but we've
made her black and white outfit stand
out even more than before
she's also reading a book which we're
sure is her collection of poems one of
our favorite poems by Lucy is the one
where she thinks Bobby was a stalker
because he left brownies in her locker
we're sure of her writing style improved
as she got older Lucy was yet another
name Chris Savino chose on his baby name
list if he ever had a girl what do you
think would modern-day Lucy be a poet or
would she have another profession that
would allow her to express herself
freely Luna loud we're telling you it's
definitely hard to pick favorite kids in
the loud house when they all come with
such hilarious personalities Luna loud
is also a unique character if you love
listening to rock music you'll love Luna
her attitude her looks stand out from
the rest and we completely adore her
short hair
she's also proven that purple is her
favorite color so we decided to keep the
purple and reimagine her as a modern-day
character we adore her punk rock outfit
so we kept her usual skull shirt a skirt
with belts and long boots we've also
shaved her hair on one side because
let's be honest it just looks really
cool we're pretty sure an adult Luna
would also have way too many piercings
but you've already seen that if you've
seen our other videos on the loud house
just like Lola luna was also a name that
belonged to a wiener dog and chris
savino's family but we can promise that
a human version of Luna is a million
times better than any table we have a
feeling modern Luna is still a rock tick
and she's either a musician or visits
way to many concerts Lynn loud everyone
has a competitive member of the family
it doesn't matter if your family is big
or small there's always that person that
loves to win and if you can't find them
in your own family it's probably you
blue mode represents all those people
and even though she's just 13 she can
pretty much beat everyone and everything
she'll turn everything into a
competition which can sometimes get
pretty annoying
well we've reimagined an adult version
of Linc and she really hasn't changed at
all in fact here's what she looked like
playing football
just like the 13 year old version of
Lynn she's sporting a red and white
outfit along with shoulder pads and
fancy trainers who loves it even though
she's super competitive she seems to be
having tons of fun when we bet an adult
would have more trophies than anyone
else on the planet Lin is also the name
of one of Chris savino's sisters and we
also bet there's also at least one
member of his family that's just as
competitive as this cartoon character we
can't decide whether Lin would teach
sports as an adult or should be too
competitive with her students and
participate in games instead Lisa loud
Lisa is such a smart four-year-old most
of us can't wait to see what she'd be
like when she's older she's the kid that
loves science but she's so good at it
she even won a Nobel Peace Prize for her
work
we love Lisa even though she has a
slightly grumpy personality and prefers
to do experiments than hang out with her
family here's our version of an adult
Lisa loud we thought we'd keep her
adorable green sweater in purple pants
but made her significantly taller than
her version on the loud house the mug
she's actually smiling and posing for a
picture we've previously reimagined Lisa
in many different ways and a lot of the
time she reminded us of dexter from
dexters laboratory but the adult version
of lisa is completely different lisa is
also in the name of one of Chris
savino's sisters although we're pretty
sure a real-life Lisa didn't win a Nobel
Peace Prize at four years old
of course we bet an adult Lisa was able
to achieve more than anyone else has in
her life how many awards do you think
she won who's your favorite on the loud
house let us know in the comments that's
it for eleven the loud house characters
then and now for more videos like this
one check out 10 the loud house
characters reimagined as opposite
genders see you next time
[Music]